we got the return of Kuma Elder Saturn
gets wrecked and serious Luffy is up and
more happen in this insane chapter that
honestly we deserved and Kuma definitely
deserved after all those flashback
chapters so make sure to stay tuned for
that at the end of the chapter let me
know if you agree that this is one of
the most satisfying chapters in one
piece to date now chill the PIR King
within and smash that like button if you
enjoy seeing one piece reviews like this
one on the Channel I want to keep them
coming make this the video youjin the
knock one by subscribing and hitting
that notification to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece reviews and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all so as we're about to
see this chapter has the very fitting
title of and I quote thank you Daddy end
quote and oh boy it is every bit as
emotional as it sounds after all this
buildup you'll know exactly what I mean
soon so we're told that the chapter
starts where last one ended and if you
somehow missed it or don't remember
because it's been a while since I did
the last one we had one of the craziest
Cliffhangers last time Bonnie was about
to give up apologizing to the memory of
Kuma that she couldn't survive after
everything he did for her but then
arriving with more hype than Goku on
Namek Kuma saves her last minute and
takes the hit not only that he grabs one
of Elder Saturn's giant Spidey legs and
prepares an epic punch kid Bonnie is
crying Saturn is worried and that
chapter Cuts before the punch connects
here we're told we start with Saturn
being shocked when he sees that Kuma is
still moving after all we know that this
shouldn't be possible but I guess that's
just the Power of Love although we do
get another interesting explanation
later as we'll see at this point it's
revealed that Saturn already pressed the
self-destruct switch a few days after
the Revolutionary Army took Kuma's body
from marijua so he understandably can't
understand what's happening this is
definitely an intriguing mystery take
your guesses now in the comments how do
you think this is possible even Vega
Punk who you could say might have pulled
one over on Saturn thinks to himself
that there is no scientific explanation
for why Kuma can still move or how he
knows Bonnie is on Egghead so that's the
really crazy part this is beyond the
doing of Vega Punk something he can't
even explain there's evidently a lot of
shocking going around here as we're told
that Sanji Frankie and Atlas are shocked
as well when they see Kuma that must be
an interesting reunion after that time
he kind of wrecked them at sabot
although of course in retrospect we know
that he was just helping them out and is
really the reason they made it this far
by the way how crazy is it to go back
and think about our thoughts way back
when that happened and Luffy was
freaking out about not being able to
save his crew and how we feel about it
now knowing Kuma's side of it it's
moments like that that make me really
want to rewatch one piece with someone
who hasn't watched it so I can just
appreciate such moments again I'm
telling you guys one of these days a one
piece rewatch from the beginning might
be in order add that to our list of
podcasts anyways back to the punch and
just before Kuma's punch reaches Saturn
Kuma remembers some parts of his life we
get nothing new we're told but still
this is huge it confirms that yes this
is the real Kuma acting not something
else and it makes everything that's
about to happen so much more satisfying
even the spoilers here can't help but
call this two-page spread we get super
epic of course it's the one where Kuma
punches Saturn you got to think about
Luffy punching the Celestial Dragon when
you see this after all that moment was
profound for Kuma as well but it's taken
up a notch here and I didn't even know
that would be possible but it is because
of how much Kuma and Bonnie suffered
because of Saturn and because Kuma is
technically a slave and Saturn is not
just any Celestial Dragon but one of the
very evil and not just stupid evil goto
besides U who is a secret this man might
as well be the highest ranking in the
world he sits at top the celestial
system and yet slave Kuma just wrecked
him paying him back as much as possible
for everything he did to his daughter in
that one emotional climactic punch this
is one of the best chapters in one piece
just because of that punch and if you
agree punch that like button like it's
Saturn's despicable spider face back to
the spoilers and Kuma's punch crushes
Saturn's face but Saturn is still
conscious and looks angry at Kuma
nevertheless Saturn is son flying across
the island he hits some buildings and
they fall on him flattening him imagine
how this all looks for the character's
present especially for the Marines and
Oda is thinking about that too and shows
us how all the Marines are shocked to
see that a slave as mentioned just
punched a member of the goto and it
doesn't hurt that the punch is such an
epic one either way better than the time
Bonnie stabbed him a bit the big way
that punch changed ches the situation on
the battlefield is that for whatever
reason people can move again Vega Punk
Sanji Frankie and Atlas realize they can
move and Sanji of course make sure to
first ask are you okay Bonnie Chan Vega
Punk asks everyone to bring Bonnie back
to the labo phase so they can escape
clearly here the focus is still being
placed on escaping not winning
suggesting that might be what's coming
perhaps Saturn will live to fight
another day but I sure hope not I mean
we got five go to say why not take one
out now Vega Punk also gives us the
important information that Kuma
self-destruct switch doesn't literally
destroy Kuma's body since Vega Punk
knows it can be weaponized Vega Punk did
follow Saturn's orders though by
creating a mechanism that will switch
off all of Kuma's function so even him
in all his wisdom and knowledge says
Kuma shouldn't be able to move or take
any order after the self-destruct switch
is pressed then he finally hints at
another possibility saying could it be
that the buccaneer Race's special
ability is not superhuman strength dot
dot dot in the past they have dot dot
dot end quote and that's as far as he
goes but the implication could be that
it's something different about the
buccaneer race that's making what should
not be possible with a normal human
possible here with Kuma then thankfully
we get the moment where Bonnie thanks
Kuma for everything she saw in Kuma's
memory thank God she got this
opportunity because I know she wanted
and needed it desperately then Kuma just
hugs Bonnie such a heartwarming and
important moment and then he stops
moving so glad Oda gave us these moments
they were so important for Bonnie's
closure and for our closure as well
obviously the ideal would be for Kuma to
come back for good but I'm just saying
if he doesn't then I'm super glad Oda
gave this epic send off however we know
Oda wouldn't let Kuma end things instead
of Luffy especially with an opponent as
hyped up as Saturn so then our attention
turns to Luffy after Kuma stops moving
and it turns out Luffy is not there
anymore the Marines can't find Luffy
anywhere he seems to have disappeared
and other words Luffy is up from where
he was and at this point he could make
his return any second he was already
fine enough to eat up last chapter
whether it was really kizaru that fed
him will get into soon enough because
kizaru also comes back into play we're
given a side note in the spoilers too
that we don't get anything new from Zoro
Luchi and other straw hats except Sanji
and Frankie and same goes for the other
Vega punks except Vega Punk and Atlas
but I'm fine with the focus being
concentrated here since this is easily
the most hype area to be right now then
we unfortunately get the inevitable
Saturn emerges from the rubble not only
is he alive the right arm he lost and
his left horn that he lost due to the
buildings falling on him in fact his
whole heavily injured body it all
recovers black Flames appear and he
regenerates seemingly 100% now like I
said we should not have expected Kuma to
come in and finish off Saturn it
wouldn't make much sense but he still
got an amazing moment which we should
appreciate he got to have a proper
goodbye with Bonnie and he did buy time
so Luffy can get better and made it
possible for the others to move again so
yes Oda allowed Kuma to have the final
epic moment he deserved even while he's
not seemingly going to use him as a save
the day completely device again as he
did at sabot and honestly I think that's
a great way for Oda To Tread the line I
think he did a great job orchestrating
this part then Saturn asks Vega Punk how
could this happen with Kuma to which the
smartest mind in the world says let's
just say it's because of love a moment
you got to appreciate especially after
seeing the amount of Love Kuma and
Bonnie have for each other Saturn then
tries to attack Kuma but Sanji deflects
Saturn's attack he says you won't hurt
Bonnie Chan again now if you'll remember
Sanji after unlocking his new insane Vin
smoke Powers hasn't really been
challenged to the max yet he wrecked and
flexed on Queen and his 1.32 billion
Berry Bounty so this will probably be
the first time we really see him push to
his new limit still don't expect to see
Sanji taking down an elder but at least
I can see him buying some time before
Luffy gets there Vega Punk then orders
Atlas to carry up Kuma to the labo phas
perhaps it's to respect his body or
perhaps he actually has a way to save
him we'll have to wait and see what
happens meanwhile Frankie isn't taking
it easy either he uses radical beam to
attack Saturn he says we owe Kuma a big
favor and yeah by my count now it's
multiple favors his attack pierces
Saturn's body but it seems like there's
no use at this point as Saturn recovers
easily from his attack since he appears
to be able to regenerate flesh this
could really be a problem especially if
real hockey attacks can also just be
regenerated from that I'm hoping Luffy's
Advanced conqueror hcky will be a
different story after all kaido said
hcky transcends all all including op
devil fruit Powers suddenly though
kizaru appears and kicks Frankie away
Mega Punk tells kizaru off so if that
theory about kizaru feeding Luffy was
right and I'm still not saying it wasn't
kizaru still isn't ready to fully make
his switch for whatever reason let's
hope he's just waiting for the right
time rather than actually being
indecisive Mega Punk even says what I've
been emphasizing this whole Arc and I
quote your heart can't withstand doing
this much longer what a sad man you are
kizaru end quote it seems like VAP Punk
also knows kizaru is a good guy at heart
and he seems to be drawing attention
like I've been doing to the disconnect
in his actions like I've been saying
this internal struggle has to come to a
head and I hope it will lead to kizaru
choosing to help the good guys and his
friends versus the evil spider Elder
demon if Blackbeard can have K on then I
think Luffy can have kizaru it would go
perfectly with the parallels between
Luffy and Blackbeard since the beginning
and if you think about it what Admiral
would work better for the sun god than
the Admiral of light think about it it
just writes itself at that point he's
clearly recognizes the truth in mega
Punk's words he has a sad expression and
it seems he's about to tear up he says I
should have brought darker sunglasses
presumably what he meant by this is that
darker sunglasses would hide his tears
or at least his sad expression in the
last page of the chapter Saturn orders
the Buster call to start on ekad island
we can see all Marine ships preparing to
start the attack so we are fast
approaching the end of this incident and
I'm hoping that we get kizaru joining
the straw hats and not just him staying
behind kind to hold off Saturn or
something either way exciting stuff and
I must say an epic chapter there will be
a chapter next week too no break so make
sure you're subscribed so you know the
second that drops like if you enjoyed
and if you did you don't want to miss my
recent video on every reaction to
Luffy's gear five so far link on screen
right now and I'll see you in the next
one